vous
non
alors d'abord je suis gonzague de
montmirail et donc descendants de
godefroy de montmirail
je pense qu avec le team que tu as kobe
qu'il allait délivrer le dauphin quelle
blague
pauvre petit dauphin contrairement au
reste de la famille il a choisi d'être
révolutionnaire pas de temps par
conviction que tout par peur des dessins
c'est un coire il sait que ça va être
dangereux
il vaut mieux être du bon côté mais
c'est ne pas que le bon côté on sait pas
trop il est donc voilà grâce à notre
grand coeur voici tous coincés ici rien
ce qui est horriblement dans le rapport
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que celui là
est pas un nouvel opus c'est un nouveau
film dans cette voie rires je te vois
rires ah ça va être difficile